The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: OK.
Before we start, I've spoken
to a quite number of you
about your papers.
I'm a little surprised that
you have so much intelligence
and so show little
in this class.
It often fascinates me.
I have various
theories to explain it,
but they're not important.
Let me start off
by asking you what
you thought about the
story of Johannesburg.
What struck you?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: What was the story
you told of the additions
to the houses?
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I guess what struck me with
that is that, you know,
on the one hand, there's
this constant appreciation
of sort of individuals' efforts
and vernacular practices
that come about.
But then those so rarely
are institutionalized
and are often restricted.
So that was one
thing that struck me.
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
these were not restricted,
nor institutionalized.
AUDIENCE: No, they weren't.
Yeah.
But I guess in
common in practice--
but here in the States, if
you're zoning through so many
things, you know that that is--
even if that's
appreciated, there's
never much thought into
how to encourage that.
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
we presume that we
passed the stage of needing
to externalize our importance.
We haven't got the
motive for doing it.
If we have, we do it in
tyranny and not externally,
so the theory would go.
We still believe,
probably, that we've
reached a level of
civilization that
doesn't require idiosyncratic
or highly personal expressions
in public.
We look at popular
art all over Africa
and say that this is a culture
which has properties, but is
still moving towards a climax.
Its climax will be--
much, though, the world of
Manhattan would be a climax.
That's one theory.
Another theory is that, in
people in the developing world,
there are not many
resources available to them.
So they have to develop
their own resources.
Later in this class, when
I talk about Slum Dwellers
International and the
latest configurations
of self-help
organization, you will
see that the strength of
people to organize themselves,
a fundamental
premise of anarchism,
is now rearing its head
as the only resource
that poor people have against
enormous bureaucratic odds.
So you can see it is a
very optimistic idea.
The successes of SDI and its
equivalent on three continents
so far would suggest
that there is something
to be gained from not exploiting
but using or collectivizing
the resources of
people in poverty
towards organizing a
better situation for them.
John Turner in Latin America,
John Aubrachen in Holland,
were both at MIT at the
time I arrived here.
And we shared stories about
what this kind of thing meant.
Any other reactions?
What about the imposition
of racial classification?
Does the market impose
similar strictures
on the location of people?
Was the South African
situation just another version,
an extreme version, of what
the market does anyway?
Remember Western Native Township
was located next to a dump.
Soweto was located next
to very obnoxious land.
I think sewage farms and so on.
Isn't this what happens?
Look, I'm looking at
extreme situations
in order to do the difficult
thing of generalizing back
to normality.
I'm not taking Boston as a case.
I'm not taking
[INAUDIBLE]---- well,
I am taking
[INAUDIBLE] as a case.
And what I'm trying to do is
what perhaps medical professors
do when looking at
teaching about cancer.
They look at the worst
case, the most extreme case
of the disease, in
order to make the point
as clearly as possible.
I think there is a sense
in my using Johannesburg.
South Africa would not have
been marginalized had it not put
race classification into law.
Nobody boycotted America in
the early years of the century,
of the last century, by
having local conditions
against Black people.
Many of the countries who
voted against South Africa
in the United
Nations were imposing
harsher, but not legalized
national constitutional devices
in favor of the separation
of white and Black
or poor and rich.
Does that make any sense?
What about rejoicing on the
products of poor people?
When poor people struggle
to maintain some decent life
beyond poverty, we rejoice.
AUDIENCE: Are you saying
this from a schadenfreude
perspective or from a--
JULIAN BEINART: Probably.
AUDIENCE: --or from a-- we
just enjoy what they produce
and enjoy the--
JULIAN BEINART: It's difficult.
I'm judging from the response
that I have had in many
parts of the world when
showing this material over
a number of years on the BBC
and all over the place.
It was on the cover of three
architectural magazines
in the same month in 1966.
It's a long time ago,
but there was something.
Whenever I went
somewhere, architects
were saying, gosh, if only we,
our clients in social housing,
had that capacity to
individuate the buildings.
And John Aubrachen,
amongst others,
made big theory in his
book supports and others
of the process of indwelling
as being something
that we should cultivate.
Architects should only build
if it required support systems
to let people finish
the work themselves.
In the three cases
which I want to deal
with very briefly
this afternoon,
we find a number of
different things operating.
The Mexican-American
border is 1,952 miles long.
It's the longest border in
the world, the least defended
and the most patrolled.
It's the largest tourist
crossing in anywhere
in the world.
Yet it has 11 binational
cities along the border.
They vary from Tijuana,
San Ysidro, San Diego,
to Ciudad Juarez, and El Paso
to the wonderful mix Californian
pair of Calexico
and Mexicali, which
is a wonderful anagram
of the linguistics.
Nogales, Nogales, Brownsville,
Matamoros on the Gulf.
How should we regard the cities?
I will show evidence to
show that they operate
in some ways as unified
metropolitan areas, which
would mean that this
subregion along the border
could be justified as
a separate identity
from either Mexico
and the United States.
AUDIENCE: When I was in
the Mexican government,
we used to study
the thesis a lot.
And I remember talking
to people especially,
in Tijuana San Diego, on
both sides of the border.
They actually refer to the
city as the Metropolitan area
Tijuana San Diego.
And their perspective
on the crossing point,
on the checkpoint
right at the border,
is [INAUDIBLE] sort of
a permanent nuisance
that they have to deal
with in their daily lives.
Because people work and
commute daily to the city.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
In all of these cases, there's
an important friction system
operating.
In this case, it's between white
people and non-white people,
between people of Hispanic
heritage or an Indian heritage
and--
El Paso is amongst the poorest
parts of the United States.
When I was on the border in--
after Jimmy Carter
became president,
I attended some of
the meetings which
he and the Mexican
president set up
on some of these border towns.
Octavio Paz says that
Mexico, crossing the border,
is one of the ways
in which Americans
satisfy their obsessions.
It refers to a larger idea.
And that is the uses of
slums in metropolitan areas.
In Sherlock Holmes,
the Prince Royal
goes off to smoke or take
cocaine in the East Indian
London.
Sherlock Holmes himself
smokes something or other.
The poorest part
of the population
provides a setting for the
doing of semi-legal or illegal
things, prostitution and so on.
So if you enlarge that and
you see Tijuana and San
Diego as a pair--
in Kevin Lynch and [INAUDIBLE]
study of San Diego of Tijuana,
which is in the
reading, it's one
of the best pieces of small
scale difficult planning
that I know.
It's in the reading
for today's class.
You get a sense of
this idea that--
remember Steve McQueen?
He's a famous
American male actor
who got cancer and a lot of
publicity associated with him
crossing the border to the
South to get the illegal drug
laetrile, which is not
available in the United States.
Of course, it didn't
kill his cancer.
But the phenomenon
of there being
a haven, a special
environment which
provides the majority
or the superior,
quote "superior" class,
with satisfactions
which are elicit in
their own surroundings.
AUDIENCE: The phenomenon
still stands today.
Close to the border, there's
a huge amount of pharmacies.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
AUDIENCE: They sell medicines
that here, in the States,
would be either restricted by a
prescription or not available.
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
two reactions to that--
the border between East
Germany and West Germany--
also, borders attract a
kind of marginal population.
There's a wonderful little
book in your reading called
On The Border by Tom Miller--
he's a New York
Times journalist--
which records a trip from
Brownsville, Matamoros
all the way to Tijuana and the
extraordinary things he find.
He finds a town
which specializes
in the smuggling of peacocks to
Chicago in the back of trucks.
He finds the most powerful AM
station in the United States,
a right-wing propaganda
radio station
which the government of
China asked the United
States to intervene with.
So there's a kind
of erotic condition
where you bring two
notions together.
I don't know what the
theory behind that is.
But it seems to be the
case that the behavior
of a lot of activities
on this border
are different from the internet.
AUDIENCE: There is a book
by the editor of Foreign
Revue [INAUDIBLE] Moises Naim.
The book is called
Illicit, where
he studies borders in
details as constructs that,
because of their--
artificial blockage of
goods, services, and people's
daily activities, it brings
out a particular kind
of inhabitant of these places.
JULIAN BEINART: This
Mexican-American border
serves a number of
other functions.
It serves as the major
avenue of illegal immigration
into the United States.
I don't know if there's
illegal immigration south
from the United States
into Mexico, but--
AUDIENCE: There are a lot
of people that go to Mexico.
We don't ask
Americans for a visa.
They enter, and then they
stay in Mexico and live there.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
There are, according
to government sources,
12 million illegal immigrants
in the United States.
The census or one of
the government agencies
claims it only arrests
one out of four people who
try to take their bodies.
56% of illegal immigrants
in this country are Mexican.
So this border serves as
an avenue for the movement
of people from--
what would you call Mexico?
What would you call
the United States?
The United States offers more,
presumably more, opportunities
for increasing wealth.
There are many stories
that are humorous
surrounding that there are
people who live in Mexico
and work in the United
States illegally every day.
One of the stories
in our meeting
was told by a young man who
dresses up in jogging clothes
like an American, crosses
the border every morning at 5
o'clock, starts jogging
on the American side
and works as a gardener,
returns home at night.
These are funny stories.
Immigration into
the United States
is politically and spatially
still very unresolved.
America was built by immigrants.
I'm an immigrant.
And I've taught
here for 34 years.
It shows how poor the
local population is.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm jumping all over the place.
I just want to cite you
statistic about immigration.
"United States remains
a magnet for immigrants.
The US is among the best
at assimilating them.
As a result, half the
world's skilled immigrants
come to the US.
Between 1990 and
2005, immigrants
started a quarter of the new
venture-backed public companies
in the United States."
So again, we are at
the crossroads theory.
On the one hand there's
the conservative position
that a nation should take
care of its own people
and selectively
choose people who
wish to get into
that country, not
have a random system of entry.
The US Congress is likely to
take up immigration following
the failure of the
previous President Bush
who comes from Texas and was
under a lot of pressure, set
about building a $60 billion
fence over the 2,000 miles.
He reduced it to 700 miles,
ran into enormous problems
of land rights in Texas
and was sued and abandoned
the whole project.
What else about the
Mexican-American border?
AUDIENCE: Right now
in Mexico, there
is a huge [INAUDIBLE]
immigration
reform because of what
happened on [INAUDIBLE]..
But they were talking
about immigration reform
in the early Bush days in 2001.
Actually, President Fox came
as well to the conference--
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --one
week before 9/11.
As soon as 9/11 happened, that
whole discussion got derailed.
And the priorities
of US policy shifted.
So it moved from an idea
of having an immigration
reform to an idea of security.
And we've been talking
about immigration.
There's a lot of talk
about immigration reform
again or getting back
into the political agenda.
And now that the marathon
bombings happened again,
you can follow it
up in Mexican media.
There's another notion
of, oh my god, it's
this story all over again.
It's happening all over again.
It's going to be the security
concerns are going to take over
the political discussion.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
Cheap labor is important in a
capitalist industrial economy.
So immigration will be
supported by capitalists--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JULIAN BEINART: --i.e.
people who politically
are normally conservative.
So there's an ambiguity
about this position.
The strength of cheap labor--
Mitt Romney was accused
of using Mexican workers
to fix his garden without
paying them legally.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN BEINART:
Anyway, what do you--
you have a population
in this belt
on either side of
the border where
people speak two languages,
share telephone services.
Industries in one country
are located across the border
into another--
there's 3,000 American
industries which pay no taxes.
They move south
across the border,
but pay tax only when
the finished products are
returned to the United States.
This is the second largest
labor source in Mexico
according to a recent
item that I read.
So we have the United States
exporting its industries
around the world to
pools of cheap labor.
One of the closest and,
therefore, reducing the costs
of transportation is Mexico.
So you have another
version of the relationship
between these two countries.
Pro this kind of
effort are people
who believe that it stimulates
jobs in a poor country.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And then there is a backward
relationship of strong--
actually, a relevant part
of the Mexican population
that feels that it's a
highly unjust situation
because the territory of most of
the western [INAUDIBLE] states
in the US used to
belong to them.
So there's a social
resentment that
has grown in parts of
the population that
has been instigated.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes, I
should have mentioned.
For so many of you not
Americans or Mexicans
that the present status of the
border is the result of war.
Much of Texas, California,
Arizona, a number of states
even going as far as Wyoming--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's California,
Nevada, Colorado, part
of Wyoming, Arizona,
New Mexico, Texas.
JULIAN BEINART: And California.
AUDIENCE: And California.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
Yeah.
There's a long history
to all of this.
Between 1846 and 1854,
the United States
won a war against Mexico
in which the United States
took possession of a large
part of the Southwest
of the current United States
and paid Mexico $18 million.
That includes the
Gadsden Purchase, which
was an additional operation.
So this border dates
back to the same date
that Haussmann took
power in Paris,
a number of European
conflagrations in 1848.
1848, there were 137,000
British troops in India.
It's a signal date, 1850, 1848.
1850-- London, the
largest city in the world,
the first European city to
be the largest since Rome.
So many things
have a [INAUDIBLE]..
But I think it's
important to point out
that this heritage,
which you point to,
is probably more likely to be
absorbed now except for people
who wish to maintain
their political enemies
against the United States.
The future for all of
these situations-- and I'm
going to try to cut
these stories short
and ask you to ponder as to
what the urban mystic response
should be to these places.
You are likely to
be asked, like I
was, to venture an opinion about
one of the days on the border
the chief planner of
Juarez, who is Mexican,
and the chief planner of El
Paso, who's Mexican-American,
met for the first time
in these discussions.
They discussed water.
They discussed
illegal settlement.
They discussed fumes that were
coming from the Asarco lead
plant into Mexico.
That night there was a dinner.
And I was sitting
next to the woman who
was the representative of the
US government Foreign Service.
And she asked me how I
was enjoying the day.
And I said, it was remarkable.
It felt so positive about this
interaction and the promises
that the people
made to each other.
She said to me,
remember, we fought a war
against these people once.
So my naive academicism
was piloted off
in a very bad direction.
What else can I say about--
read Tom Miller's book
if you want to know
what the border is like.
I think we'll leave the
Mexican-American bipolar
series.
The piece I gave
you in the handout
today from 1981 US
News and World Report--
"Where Yanks and Mexicans
Live Together and Like It."
"Linked by twin
industries, two-way trade,
and now by trolley line,
San Diego and Tijuana
offer an object lesson in
international cooperation."
I don't know if
that is justified,
but I leave it to you to
make a judgment about that.
The fact is that there
are not many conditions
in the world where two nations,
one presumably belonging
to the First World, another
belonging presumably
to the Second World, go inside.
European cities extend
their labor relationships
across to North Africa to
Turkey as migrant labor.
South Africa built its
gold mines on migrant labor
from as far north as
Malawi and Tanzania.
But here we have a
conjunction of two systems
around urban areas, which
are just a fence away
from each other.
One of the models for
the future of Jerusalem
was, in fact, a
kind of city which
had no border running
through the city.
It wasn't a divided city
at all, but the city
which mediated issues such
as customs and security
in other ways.
Maybe with electronic
technology we'll
be able to introduce
ways of assessing
personal movement and personal
behavior more adequately.
One is always fascinated by what
happened on Monday afternoon
here in Boston.
This lecture is being recorded,
so I have to add the date.
This is the Monday after
the marathon bombing.
How much evidence
seems to be available
simply through the common
practice of people, teenagers
having telephones
which record material?
So one maybe in future be
able to see enormous diversity
to cities, given an
environment of relative peace.
If you look back historically at
Europe, the wars between Spain
and Holland, between
Spain and England,
between France and Germany,
between Germany and Poland
and Russia, between
Napoleon and northern Italy,
between the Muslim city
of Istanbul and Budapest
and Vienna.
I mean, I'm not even
going very far back.
I'm going back to the 18th
century, 17th century.
To believe, at that
time, that there
would be a common union
in which there would
be no passports required to
move from France into Belgium
or from France into
Germany would have
been impossible to imagine.
One of the things I
learned from Kevin Lynch
was his incredible belief in
the capacity of human beings
to improve themselves.
And his evidence was
always that urbanism
could be properly administered,
be a vehicle for doing this.
Cities educate people.
They teach them new ways.
Johannesburg is not
the city that it
was when Soweto was created.
The reason, as I mentioned
over and over again last week,
was the South Africa
sought for a rural solution
to its problems because
urbanism educated people
to their political
right, to [INAUDIBLE]..
And the Bantustan
policy which was
the last of the major efforts
by the Afrikaner government
in South Africa was anti-urban.
We move to the
broad body of stuff,
which we normally refer to as
colonial-native relationships.
A colonial-native
relationship is a relationship
in which a dominant external
force occupies another country
and imposes its will around
a number of polarities.
For Britain it was
dangerous to go to India.
The life expectancy
of a British soldier,
if they stayed in Britain
in 1883, was 59.5 years.
If they went to India,
it was 37.7 years.
So the preoccupation
of the British
was that India was an
extraordinary environment.
It was dangerous.
It was also seductive.
The British, under
Victorian rule,
by and large
repressed sexuality.
You come to India where
sexuality is abundant
not in terms of
personal behavior,
but in terms of
cultural expression.
If you really E.M. Forster's
book of Passage to India
in 1924--
has anybody read Forster?
He's one of the greatest
English writers.
You must read him.
Read a Passage to India.
You'll get a--
look what happens.
A young English
woman called Adele
arrives in India to marry
the son of the Mrs. Briggs,
I think.
I'm not sure.
I don't remember.
They meet a handsome young
Indian doctor called Dr. Aziz.
Dr. Aziz is a
trained medical man.
And the interaction
is quite spontaneous.
Dr. Aziz invites them, the
mother and this young woman,
to visit some caves nearby
called the cave the Macabar.
This is all fictitious, of
course, but you see the story.
This young woman is so
distraught in the caves
by the echo that
come back whenever
they speak that she goes off.
She goes crazy and runs away.
She comes back to the
British civil station
and accuses Dr. Aziz of
having assaulted sexually.
The British claim that
Indian men are sexually
attracted to white
British women and should
be punished for that.
The Indians claim
that this is a hoax,
that this woman was hysterical.
It goes to court and Dr. Aziz
is, at the end of the book,
freed from the case because
this woman breaks down in court
and admits that she made
the wrong accusation.
AUDIENCE: There's
a very telling part
of in the story about the button
on the back of the shirt, which
Dr. Aziz shares to an
Englishman, but had forgotten.
And then when they're
qualifying Dr. Aziz
and they get to the button,
they link that to the notion
that no Indian could ever
behave like a true gentlemen
because they forget
the small details.
[LAUGHTER]
So they tie it down.
And it tells you a
lot of the rigidity
that society played on
all those small constructs
as artificial
classifiers of people.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
You know, it raises
another issue for me.
And that is we require novelists
to see a situation and write
about it in a way that
reality cannot do.
That is for those of
you interested in film
and its impact on our
understanding of cities.
There's so many movies
which depict conditions
in cities in heightened form.
It took E.M. Forster sitting at
Cambridge to write a book at--
he visited India.
Anyway, so here the
polarities are complex.
For the British, they
were three diseases
that had to be counted,
environmental diseases
of the air, vegetation,
soil, water, humidity.
Number two-- behavioral
diseases, diet, alcohol.
And number three-- social
diseases, sexual diseases.
I will show you
some of the images
from some of the literature.
One of the notions
was that disease,
as in London about
the same time,
was carried through the air.
So the ventilation system in
the bungalow and in the hat
was a similar situation which
allowed air to pass through.
I will show you a section
through a parade ground, which
is ventilated up and down.
I'll show you a diagram
of the amount of air
you need to be safe.
This is all before Snow and
the discovery of cholera
as the waterborne disease.
The choice, you will
see, for an Indian,
at least for an
English bureaucrat,
was between a bungalow--
bungalow, again, is a term which
comes from the native language,
from [NON-ENGLISH].
You must remember
that the headquarters
of the capital of India
with Calcutta before it
was moved by the British
to Delhi from a [LAUGHTER]
world, world of speaking
another language to Hindu.
The word veranda is
also a word that's
been built into
English architecture.
There are a number
these terms which
refer to spatial components
of the colonial city--
the maidan, which
is that breathing
space of open space
between the native city,
much like South Africa.
The native city and the
new white enterprise
would be separated by space.
Critical distance
was another feature
of the dominant-native
relationship.
You want to be as far
as possible from them.
A book colonial city argues that
the French colonial environment
was different because
the French have always
assumed a more liberal
position about body contact.
And the British have
always resisted.
So the British-- the
notion of staying
as far away from the native
not only because of the air,
but of some kind of
distancing of context,
metaphysical perhaps, but
also physical and spatial.
Typically, the British built
a military presence first
or the cantonment on the
other side of the maidan,
and then built what is
called the civil station just
beyond the cantonment.
The civil station
was, again, a set
of bungalows spaced like a
suburban American landscape
with enough air floating
around, and nothing was dense.
The native city was dense.
I'll show you some
images of the native city
from the British view.
So attenuated space was
an important component.
I've given you two pages
on the next big adventure,
and that's the
building of New Delhi.
The building of New Delhi,
or the planning in New Delhi,
took a number of forms.
One of the important
members of the committee
was a man called Lanchester,
John Lanchester, who
was an acolyte of Patrick
Geddes and believed
in constructive surgery.
So his first ambition
was to link the new plan
to the native city of
Shahjahanabad, which
is one of the oldest
cities in the Far East.
I think since--
God only knows-- the 13th.
When was the origin
of Shahjahanabad?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Prior to Shah
Jahan, it was a settlement.
In the 14th century, it was
considered the largest city
in the Far East.
So Shahjahanabad,
after the riots,
the British took over
parts of Shahjahanabad
and made it a military
presence as well.
But Lanchester's plan was
to try to link Shahjahanabad
to this new development.
There are various iterations by
the architect Sir Edwin Lutyens
and Sir Herbert Baker.
Here what I've given
you is a sketch
of five different planned
discussions ultimately
resulting on the Raisina Hill
solution, the [INAUDIBLE] Hill
Solution.
The notion which
prevails throughout
is that British classicism
or the British interpretation
of Greek and Roman
classicism was
a way of educating the native
population to standards
which they couldn't
achieve by themselves.
The second one was that the site
needed to be high in elevation,
so that it would
dominate the world.
These are primitive
ideas which you
can see in the
laws of the Indies
as well of a
colonial proposition
needing to educate and
subdue the population.
Remember, in the
laws of the India,
the rules are that
the natives are not
allowed to see the cathedral
until it's finished.
You have to use the force
of the cathedral's elevation
to dominate.
You cannot see the
construction of the cathedral.
The construction is a process
of admitting viability--
not admitting viability--
admitting weakness.
So Edwin Lutyens, who was
a very good architect--
you should look.
For those who are
interested in architecture,
look at his project Lindisfarne
in England quite different
from this.
Anyway, I'll just
quote the manifestation
of some of these ideas.
"Indian buildings,
even the Taj Mahal,
were picturesque and
decorative, but pervaded
by childish ignorance
of the basic principles
of architecture.
The Indic style,
he argued, simply
does not have the constructive
and geometrical qualities
necessary to embody the
idea of law and order, which
is being produced out of chaos
by the British administration.
Would [INAUDIBLE],, he
wrote sarcastically,
had he gone to Australia,
have burnt his knowledge
and experience to produce
a marsupial style?"
Can you imagine a marsupial
style in Australia?
His argument is that to
disembody classicism, which
had been produced out
of centuries of thought
by Europeans, to disembody it
and to make it into Indianism
would not only be
difficult and foolish,
but would not
embody the purposes
of British colonialism.
That is to educate and
maintain dominance over people.
So correctly speaking,
classicism used in this sense
is a disembodiment
of the universality
of human experience.
He says that human experience
is manifest at a higher
level in 500 BC in
Greece and is maintained
for 2000 years as the
dominant form of expression
in architecture
not to be vitiated
by any local cultural evidence.
Of course, there were no
great Indian architects.
One has to look at Chandigarh
as another importation
of a European architect to deal
with this question of what is
Indian and what is universal.
We'll deal with Chandigarh in
this class if we have time.
I recently wrote a
piece on Chandigarh
for a book, which is
a result of a talk we
gave at the 50th
anniversary of Chandigarh.
So all of this adds up to
a very concise explanation
of the planning and
architectural content
of New Delhi as being an
expressive and controlled
system of dominance.
We need to know now--
and I have many post-colonial
Indian architect friends
and have been in
partnership with one.
So I think I understand a
little bit about their reaction.
Modernism was a
vehicle for destroying
all kinds of notions of
colonial-native relationships,
I think.
Do you think so?
AUDIENCE: In some
way, not entirely.
JULIAN BEINART: Not entirely--
but there were people like
Rudyard Kipling and his father,
who also were British, who
took a different view of India.
So I suppose they were
eccentric to India.
but modernism has
allowed India to bypass
the question of style in a sense
as being politically important.
I mean, people like [INAUDIBLE]
and many others have used
modernism as a free liberal
expression of what they think
a new society should be about
despite the polarities between
Hindu and Muslim in
the current India,
despite the enormous polarities
between wealth and poverty
after--
anyway, so what do you think?
AUDIENCE: I think
modernism has replaced
even a lot of the traditional
Indian [INAUDIBLE] have.
The Indian architecture has
been influenced by [INAUDIBLE]..
And there's so many influences.
JULIAN BEINART: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: By saying that
modernism is a free expression
or is something that negates
all of that does not really--
I don't know.
It doesn't sound--
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
it doesn't negate it.
But it was agnostic.
It did not associate
itself with anything else,
but its own invention.
In doing so, it denied the
aspirations of Indianism maybe.
AUDIENCE: But what is Indianism?
Because [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN BEINART:
Well, absolutely.
So Chandigarh was easy to--
Nehru understood
that to get Corbusier
to come along and design
his image of new capital
city for the Punjab
would require somebody
who had the capacity
to overwhelm
the Indianness in the same way
that Louis Khan in Bangladesh
built his world in Dhaka.
Le Corbusier traveled
all over India before.
He writes all about
Indian construction
and Indian materials.
Louis Khan does the same thing.
Louis Khan buildings,
parliament building,
marks the end of a day of work.
And then the next day,
the bricks or the stones
are sort of marked in relation
to the labor as if this is--
I mean, this is
another big story.
But let's leave the
story to concentrate
on racial polarities.
Maybe these extreme polarities
disappear with education,
disappear with change, so
liberals would believe.
AUDIENCE: So what
are you saying,
that through
education [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN BEINART:
Through education one
presumes that changes
in idle worship
transform people to being
religious [INAUDIBLE]
in history.
The European evidence of the--
there's no animation-- no, not
animation, no active hostility
between Spain and Holland.
Although the Spanish did
terrible things to them.
We're going to do a class
on architecture and memory
or urbanism and memory
because some of this
has been written about.
I do believe that the only
solution for Jerusalem,
if there is any solution,
which is going to take time,
is if there were some force
which introduced itself
into Israeli education.
Israeli education is dominated
by the religious groups, who
insist on portraying Arabs
as rapists, and villains,
and so on.
The reverse is true.
If you look at the
high school books, some
of the books in
Jordan, and Syria,
and so on, they depict Jews
as Shakespeare depicted
the Merchant of Venice.
Now, you don't go around
England any more writing
books about Jews as
the Merchant of Venice.
That stopped in
the 16th century.
So there's historic
evidence that people do,
cultures do, change their mind.
What about the future
of Johannesburg?
There are 40 million Black
people in South Africa today.
There are 6 million whites
and 6 million coloreds making
a [INAUDIBLE] population.
That means that Black people
are 80% of the total population
of South Africa today.
What is the policy
with regard to Soweto?
You are a brilliant
MIT graduate.
You're hired by
the United Nations
to advise the South African
government, as I was.
What do you do?
You've got to take care
of rebuilding education
for 40 million people.
You've got to introduce
health systems.
You've got to provide jobs.
25% of young Blacks in
Johannesburg don't have jobs.
You can't socialize the
society quickly enough
because foreign
investment, which
is fundamental to South
Africa's capital, will flee.
So you cannot nationalize
the gold mines,
as many of the ANC
people have wanted to do.
So let's look at Havana
and Cuba for a moment
simply before we
write all of these
off as the dustbins of history.
Look, this is tough stuff.
It's not urban designers
planting a few trees in Iowa.
This is what is happening by
and large in important parts
of the world and has happened.
You've got to have
some understanding
of these extremely
difficult situations.
Havana was a Laws
of the Indies city.
Between 1959 and 1988, it was
host to Soviet sponsorship.
And as I look at
the plans for when
we were in Havana and in
end of 1978, I think--
a couple of things.
One of the ideas
taken from Russia
was to normalize
the relationship
between the country
and the city.
If you remember Shirov's
plan for Moscow,
which I discussed
with you, there
was an attempt to
increase public space
on the periphery of the city
in a wide belt around the city.
The only city in the world where
this has been put into place
is Havana.
Lenin Park has increased
the number of square foot.
In 1959, there was 1 square
meter of open space per capita
in the city.
In 1978, when we
were there, it had
increased in 11 square meters
per capita, 3 in the city,
8 outside in Lenin Park.
Whether people
are actively using
Lenin Park is another story.
Right from the first
Castro invasion,
it seemed that the
idea was to frustrate
the growth of the city
and favor the development
of the countryside.
Again, this idea is central to
South African apartheid, which
I mentioned over and over again,
but with a different meaning.
You couldn't easily
migrate into Havana
unless you could find a job.
At least you had
somewhere to stay.
The population of
Havana decreased
after Castro's takeover.
Instead of the huts and
small property ownership,
a new rural environment
was created.
Small towns of 2,000 people
about 10 kilometers apart
were attempt--
I'll show you some of them--
to put a kind of layer of
measles across the land,
all an attempt to rejuvenate
the idea of the country.
One of the first things
that Castro did--
Castro himself, his
government, his policies--
were to take to send young
men and women from Havana out
into the country to
talk to older people
and to try to teach them
how to read and write.
The whole image
was a kind of world
in which there was the
division between rural poverty
and urban wealth
would be destroyed.
I often think
Israel and Cuba have
a lot in common by virtue
of being small countries.
In small countries, you have a
presence of the land in much--
how does a kid growing up in
New Jersey know about Yosemite?
It's too large.
It's too long.
It's too big.
It takes special effort.
But if you're living
in Havana and it
takes 5 minutes to
get into the country,
it's a different story.
Young Jews in Israel
are enormously
competent at biblical history
partly for political reasons,
but also partly because
the sites are there.
You go south to
the Negev, and you
can see where [INAUDIBLE]
sacrifice sheep or whatever.
I'm just making that up.
[INAUDIBLE] didn't
sacrifice any sheep.
So the Picadura Valley,
one of the major changes
in the rural landscape, was
to the Picadura Valley was--
there are two major industries,
agricultural industries
in Cuba, the
production of tobacco,
which is a refined
cultured the industry
and the production of sugar,
which is the harshest industry,
agricultural industry there is.
Castro made important efforts
to utilize these symbols.
He didn't nationalize
the tobacco industry.
He allowed it to remain
under local control,
but not nationalized.
He nationalized the sugar
production industry completely
and reduced its size.
In the Picadura
Valley, for instance,
he removed all sugar growth
and resurfaced the land
with new agricultural
material, got
Canada to help them to produce
a cow which could produce milk
in the tropics.
The Picadura Valley now
produces milk for Cuba.
These are important
elements of transforming
the rural productive world.
So the polarity, which I want
to focus on here, is just--
there are many
other aspects of--
by the way, modernism,
when we visited,
was the only style
of building that
was available in modern
Cuba, decorated modernism
using super graphics was very--
I'll show some of
these products.
The use of the
past selectively--
for instance, the
operation which
sent Cuban troops to Angola
to help the African Liberation
movement was called
Operation Carlota.
Who is Carlota?
Carlota was this woman
slave who led the rebellion
against the United
Fruit Company.
It was a political move to--
oh, god, I forgot
about the time.
This is so interesting.
Let's just leave it at that.
The Cuban story has transformed,
of course, since 1978.
I'm talking about a time
when the pure impulse
under Soviet
dominance, the change--
the use of micro brigade labor
and so a whole set of things
which operated at that time.
Cuba is now a
semi-socialist state,
opening up to diverse
forms of homeownership,
property ownership, different
categories of tourism,
and so on.
You see how much land of the
Southwest of the United States
Mexico controlled in 1821,
1836, 1848 to 1854, and 1980.
This diagram indicates
the special list
of a region of 11 bipolar
cities strung over 2,000 miles.
Next.
This is a famous--
Ricardo, you were
referring to this image.
This is a Mexican
settlement up to the border
in the case of Tijuana, various
conditions from Tom Miller's
book of the border running
across this vast distance.
Next.
Kevin Lynch and Donald
Appleyard's work
looking at the regional
relationship between Tijuana
and San Diego
showing how water--
water is one of the biggest
concerns between the United
States and--
the United States claims that
Mexico owes the United States
something like 60 billion
whatever, gallons of water,
which Mexico has illegally used
to supplement its population.
Water is an issue in Mexico--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN BEINART: --severe issue.
Next.
This was at the time--
tourists, $5 million per year.
It's obviously much more today.
Next.
Use of the region by La
Jolla High School students--
use of the region by
Tijuana residence.
Next.
The linear, dense,
arterial street
of the Mexican environment--
the isolated shopping center
in the San Diego space.
Next.
This is a plaza
in Ciudad Juarez.
This is a view of the
central part of El Paso.
There's one person, two people
available in the photograph.
This is all due to a whole
complex juxtaposition
of urban renewal and so on.
Next.
Despite the operation
of two separate cities,
the daily traffic
volume represents that
of a unified metropolitan area.
Next.
This is a happy
picture on the right
of border guards on
the American side
on the right playing
against Mexican border
guards on the left.
Nobody knows who wins.
The border is in the air.
Next.
Immigrant crossing-- next.
An Octavio Paz--
Americans come to Mexico to
satisfy their obsessions.
AUDIENCE: There is a
[INAUDIBLE] that is very much
ingrained in Mexican psyche.
And it's about the crosses
and the little memorials
of people that
have died crossing
from Mexico to the States.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They turn up
in places like Arizona.
They're actually
actively hunted down.
JULIAN BEINART: I
thought you were
going to refer to the
6,000 people who were
killed per annum in Juarez.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, yeah.
And then it goes on the
other way around in Juarez.
Especially women working
in rural maquilas.
JULIAN BEINART: In the
maquila industries.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, in the
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
Apparently, real
estate in Juarez,
according to The
Wall Street Journal,
is more expensive than in
an American industrial site.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN BEINART: What
accounts for the violence?
AUDIENCE: What?
JULIAN BEINART: What
accounts for the violence?
The 6,000--
AUDIENCE: There's been
a lot of wild theories,
anywhere from gang to
cults to women trafficking
to the States for
sexual purposes.
But what is very strong is the
fact that the majority of them
are women that work in maquilas.
And most of them are abducted
while on their way to work.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
Sorry, we have to carry on.
Maquilas are the name given
for American industries which
locate in Mexico, maquiladoras.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN BEINART: Next.
Here's the native city
Shahjahanabad, 1683 Shah Jahan,
and so on and so
on, the cantonment,
and the civil station.
Next.
The dense native city--
and the depiction on the
postcard of the British view
of that city.
It looks a bit like
Moscow in its early days.
Everything is seen
from a distance.
Next.
Here is the calculation
of the amount of air
you need to be safe.
Here is the attempt to
ventilate a parade ground.
Next.
The basilica form,
which allows ventilation
through at upper level--
and the headdress modeled
after the basilica form.
Next.
The layout of the
civil station, this
is an interesting
cartoon from [INAUDIBLE]..
Ensign Green is appointed
as junior commissioner
in [INAUDIBLE].
His friends suggest he needs
to get a house on the right.
The house on the right is
the scientific version,
above the ground,
ventilation everywhere.
He's determined to build
this kind of house, however.
This kind of house negates
all the scientific premises,
but it has all of the meaningful
elements to which we associate
with formal exposition.
He hasn't got the money
to build this number two,
so he ends up with number four,
a native kind of construction
called the bungalow.
Next-- from the bungalow
to the various versions
of construction.
Next.
The British maintenance of
some of the outdoor practices--
here the playing of garden
games or social events.
The maidan-- the
space that's left
between the native settlement
in Calcutta, the veranda.
Next.
The final plan--
Shahjahanabad about on
the north Connaught place,
a commercial environment
as a stepping stone
to the New Delhi.
Next-- many of the
spatial forms used
from the day of the
Persians onwards.
Next-- Connaught Place.
Next-- the great Viceroy's
Palace with the chanceries
on either side--
the secretariats, I'm
sorry, on either side.
Herbert Baker is
regarded as attempting
to introduce the Indianic
experiment into the [INAUDIBLE]
system in detail.
Next.
Havana-- the Laws of the
Indies plan on the right.
Next.
The empty city--
I'm sorry the slide is
so dark on the left.
Next.
1978-- the suburban house
is divided into two.
And a major attempt is made
to use Eastern European
prefabricated material--
We'll be through in a second--
with micro brigade
labor, teams of 33 people
from industry building their own
housing with specialist help.
Next.
Buildings which are
kept, a hut on the left,
is an attempt to show what Cuba
was like and colonial power.
The building on the
right has only recently
been opened again.
This building was closed.
When we were there, it
was considered unsafe.
But in fact, it indicated
the kind of architecture
which was too personal.
Next.
This is an interesting--
this is the premises of
the City Bank of New York.
Just on the wall as you
go beyond these columns,
there's a plaque which
says, this building
is now used for the children of
Cuba, not for capitalist use.
So you maintain the
distinction between what it was
in the past and the present.
This is the same version.
What is this saying?
The Picadura Valley
on the right is
a bunch of new rural people
with a Bulgarian television set.
Next-- Lenin Park and the
super graphics on the right.
Next-- the use of
powerful political images.
Next.
I think that the last.